good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday or at
least it was a happy tuesday until 10
minutes ago when claudia and i just
wrapped the first story
having so much fun laughing out loud
claudia's computer freezes and we lose
the whole episode so now we are starting
from the top which is probably
my least favorite thing ever
but we have so much to talk about and so
much to say that it's worth doing it all
over again no but there are some
episodes where i just don't feel like
i'm doing my best and i'm like you know
what if this whole thing freezes right
now we have to start over like i won't
care but it only happens on the days we
were being so funny our banter was on
fleek like of course we're making points
left right and center points points
points
right and we had covered so much
groundwork already like we had so many
housekeeping announcements like we had
just done the work and now we were like
35 minutes in but you know what with
every challenge comes a new opportunity
very very true so we're gonna give you
guys everything that we've got and it
really is a great show because we have a
lot to talk about today we've got the
fast five claudia has content content
content what did you watch yesterday
what will you be adding to the tv recap
today
so we're gonna change things up because
we've got a couple housekeeping
announcements you know every tuesday we
do our deer toasters we're gonna move
that to tomorrow just because today is
such a big day already and jackie has an
important doctor's appointment and we
just can't have you be late for elsie
that would be hella disrespectful of us
so disrespectful he would not stand for
it
he would not but yesterday in my bedroom
that i'm like staying at in brian's
house i did find a tv that i didn't know
was in the room and so i really spent
all day fully invested in content i did
catch up on euphoria i would like to do
a mini tv recap with that i also did
start the new season of drag race and
the new season of summer house both of
those i'm not fully caught up on but i
do want to give my initial thoughts on
the two shows two great shows two shows
that i would like to add into the
rotation so we're gonna do a mini tv
recap today push dear toasters until
tomorrow
and
what's even more exciting
is jackie and i
have decided to add a new segment to our
show you know we do the same [ __ ] we're
very
we're very templated like we do the same
show there's
you know we're consistent
but we've decided to change things up
one episode a week and that's going to
be on mondays correct it's going to be
on mondays the new segment which was an
idea from a toaster named cat so i just
want to say to kat thank you so much we
get so many unsolicited ideas advice for
the show like in our dms and i saw this
one and i was like i sent it to claudia
i was like yes yes yes
the new segment is going to be called
unburden yourself we will air it on
mondays
so that you guys can share your
embarrassing stories whatever is
weighing on you you want to let it off
your chest i imagine a lot of it will
come from some weekend antics and on
mondays we're going to unburden
ourselves and we are going to share
these stories let you get that off your
chest and for anyone who's like
listening at home who's also having a
moral hangover and a ton of anxiety i
think it will make everyone feel you
know a little less
embarrassed
it's a safe space for you to just
unburden yourselves and so if you want
to submit it's going to be unburden
yourselves
at gmail.com again totally anonymous
just like to your toasters we'll never
out you but i do think it will be
immensely helpful not only for you to
again unburden yourself but for all of
us you know we can laugh at it move on
from it and officially unburden so
unburden yourselves at gmail.com always
anonymous anything awkward that happened
to you on the weekend come monday
morning we're washing our hands we are
letting it go we are moving on yes
because once you we can laugh about
something it can no longer hurt you
we've seen this numerous times with
claudius falls and i think every time
you come on every time you fall and then
every time you come on and tell us about
it like i do think some of the pain
lifts and i just want to be that for
others as well and i think we can all
come together even toe secrets it just
goes to show you like
people do some crazy stuff some
embarrassing things you know some things
that just like when you think about you
actually like make a face like a cringe
face grimace yeah oh my god that is the
worst i could have like that yes with
you for like years like i'll think of
something that i did like a year ago and
i'm like
like
ooh
but i can tell you firsthand it does
make a world of difference to talk about
it like it really does so i think monday
mornings are going to be a very
important show for us moving forward
yeah so we're really excited about that
so make sure you email us
onbirdingyourselves gmail.com
other than that it was business as usual
i spent my day yesterday reading the
book for the redheads ghost of gotham by
craig shafer
and it is so disturbing and i had no
idea that it was going to be like this
violent and gory
and because this book came
recommended from not our usual like good
reads lists of like here's what you
should read next
i don't think anyone in the redheads
community had read it and so there's no
trigger warning even though i guess the
warning would just be like
immense violence
and it's been a lot it's been a lot to
digest so i didn't turn my tv on
yesterday i've just been reading for the
redheads new episode shops thursday but
the good thing about having like a crazy
book is the episode pops off because you
want to know what the snatcher was
thinking when she read this book
so
beyond curious for what the counselor
has to say the more controversial the
book the better the episode therefore
i'm really excited to record with the
girls put out the episode thursday as
always email your questions about the
book to the redheadsbookclub gmail.com
and remember it's never too late to
become a redhead
oh that's a good point because i was
actually gonna ask do you think it's
possible for someone to be
too late you know to the redheads
community no it's not and the beauty of
the redheads is like it's that all the
content is extremely evergreen so you
can choose any book from the last two
years we're coming up on our two year
anniversary of redheads and wow it'll
feel totally afresh so even if this
month's book's not for you
take a look at our catalog we have
plenty of genres i think the only genre
we haven't done yet so far is
non-fiction and i don't know if that's
going to change anytime soon
oh no we did uh
nope yeah
oh yearbook and um i know why the caged
bird sings by maya angelou never mind i
take it back yeah
um okay that's good to know because i
actually did think for a minute that it
might be too late for someone to become
a redhead so i'm really really
i'm relieved to know that it's not
so now you're out of excuses i really
would like for you literally to read a
book from the redheads and listen to an
episode why haven't you done that i i
mean i i don't know like
i just i have such a weird reading
schedule and i can't explain why like i
just i haven't but i really should
yeah and you've also read some of our
books like nothing to see here before we
were strangers
oh yeah oh she just listened to the
episode yeah well now it's a little late
so pick one other book and
join it's never too late i thought i
thought it's never too late jackie
you got me there you got me good yeah
um also speaking of content yesterday we
posted our fifth and final episode on
patreon for the month of january and
it's a hit it's a vlog of um
our journey over the weekend at our
parks casino show counselor really took
a lot of the footage so did i and then
we showed you guys a little behind the
scenes of what went down at brian's farm
we got a nice little cameo from his
brand new miniature horse named ginger
kelly
who was um
brian rescued this miniature horse it's
actually a really sad story so ginger is
like 12 or 13 years old and up until
recently she was like stuck in like a
residential home living in the home
eating dog food so obviously when when
brian heard about that he rescued ginger
and now she's living her best life on
this like crazy ass farm
i did not know that story i'm like
i'm heart sick it's so sad that is so
sad yeah you know it's like
people like domesticate pets that like
they can't
you know and they don't understand like
the the responsibility so i do believe
that's what happened with ginger
damn i love the vlog because i felt like
i was actually there i feel like i
was a fly on the wall of your weekend
and fomo has abated but also brew loved
the vlog because he fell in love with
ginger spice he was just like wanting to
go into my computer plus i now have this
new big computer with the big screen so
he was like
snout to the lens it was really
really cute the vlog was really
enjoyable and you can head over to
patreon.com morning toast also a bit of
housekeeping news that didn't make the
previous episode so maybe this is the
reason why
we're supposed to be doing it again
yeah
so i'm going on maternity leave soon of
course
but he treats yeah doing that
um
so my last show will be february 11th i
believe but you know anything could
happen so
you never right if you go until like
labor yeah yeah so but patreon there
will still be five episodes for the
month of february on patreon so if
you're missing us i would say head over
to
patreon.com you'll get new content
you'll have the old content to get you
through the one month off i'll be off
well the show will be off completely for
one month and then we'll be coming back
um
but it will be different every day based
on my availability claudia will have
co-hosts
there's just gonna be a lot going on
which that part you guys knew but um
february 11th would be my last show and
it's february first today which is
so crazy crazy so crazy
so i just want to say
the toasters have been incredibly
obviously like you are entitled to a
maternity leave but it's just weird when
like you are a podcaster and like you
pun it's it's unchartered territory so i
just want to say that the the toasters
have been extremely supportive of you
like taking as much time as you need you
know i support you if you don't want to
come back for like another week i will
hold it down you have i cannot believe
you're still podcasting like literally
if that was me i would have been tapped
out like four months ago you're
literally a hero
thank you i mean my plan is to take it
like day by day and see how i feel and
not put too much pressure on myself but
we obviously like had to make decisions
for the planning of the show and so
that's the plan right now but um
i i mean i hope i'm like so excited to
be able to come back and and share but i
don't know what i'll be feeling and
doing so
everything is in flux but we take it day
by day after the one month off there
will be shows with or without me is the
plan
yes
okay okay well you take as much time as
you need thank you thank you very much
so now i guess with further ado i think
we covered everything that we had
covered the first time and i feel with
further ado
without further ado because we've been
making much ado about nothing
did i
do
do
yes yesterday theo made his way up to
pennsylvania he's finally here i can
relax he's having the best time he's
literally sitting right on the couch
next to me for some reason does bruno do
this like he's obsessed with sleeping in
my suitcase
oh
no bruno's not done that that is not
done
it's so cute i mean last night we went
to dinner for like an hour i came back
theo was passed out in my suitcase like
he only really does it when we're not
away from home which i think makes a lot
of sense because he smells like the
house and he just he doesn't want us he
doesn't want to get left behind
damn that's really cute do just
doing do tings you absolutely love to
see it
he's doing the damn thing
yeah
he's doing this
if i weren't doing this also i'm so glad
to see that you have all of your
favorite boys surrounding you you have
do you have the spooky scary skeletons
which are always a pleasure for the
youtubers like how those boys live
rent-free in my mind you can't even know
spooky scary skeletons and shivers down
your spine yeah you want to know why
i've actually realized why i've been
wearing these so much on the podcast is
because ever since we went remote
because of kovid i have been traveling
actually quite a bit and i've been
podcasting from all over this great
nation and with tour and i always pack
one pair of pajamas with me on tour and
usually it is the pair that i'm
currently wearing so it actually makes a
lot of sense when you think about it i
think i need to um
seek out like a a custom
like dressmaker get me one and have them
make me a pair of those pajamas because
the joy that they bring me when i see
them on you like i could be wearing them
all the time and have that same joy
so actually at the meet and greet um in
dc a toaster was like i got the spooky
scary skeletons and they didn't come in
time but i was planning on wearing them
to the show and i'm like where the [ __ ]
did you find them you know what she
found them poshmark
wow
oh my god that's so smart that if
someone comes to your show in spooky
scary skeletons that would be the most
iconic thing i ever saw
i would have to cancel the show i would
be too overwhelmed with emotion
yeah
[Laughter]
damn okay
well now i think without further ado we
can jump right in because we have a lot
to discuss today are we have a whole
wide range array of stories and i'm
looking forward to getting your take on
all of them so without
further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
imperfect foods here's a cringeworthy
statistic to start off 2022. each year
35 of the food supply goes unsold or
uneaten in the u.s but imperfect foods
is working to turn this around by
sourcing foods that would otherwise fall
through the cracks of our food system so
imperfect foods is a grocery delivery
service and they offer an entire line of
sustainable groceries they taste
delicious and they reduce waste just by
embracing the natural imperfections in
food so getting groceries delivered is
just like something i'm very passionate
about and imperfect foods is in my
opinion
one of the greatest companies out there
because not only do they package and
deliver your food so luxuriously but
they're also doing great work for the
environment like there's no reason that
our country should have so much food
waste and imperfect foods is really
working towards fixing that and what i
love about it
because i just hate having like stuff in
my apartment i can't explain it um they
have
they have guilt-free packaging so
they're the only national grocery
delivery company that makes it easy to
return your packaging after every order
so you're not stuck with a tons of
wasteful like styrofoam and cardboard
but they also just help you send it back
so it's like my apartment's too small
like i don't have space for all this
packaging so sending it back i've never
seen a company do that i love it i love
just getting food delivered to my home
and there's no reason not to use
imperfect foods they're offering our
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and the promo code is tmt as in the
morning toast acronym again twenty
percent off your first four orders which
is an up to an eighty dollar value at
imperfectfoods.com and the offer code
when you
type in is tmt to get that 20 off join
the movement at imperfectfoods.com and
use code tmt
and today's episode is also brought to
you by best fiends a mobile puzzle game
that anyone can download and play
whether you have a few minutes or a few
hours best fiends is the perfect puzzle
game to lose yourself in because you're
having so much fun so i'm not even
embarrassed to say i'm on like level 400
of best fiends because i travel a lot so
i'm always like in airports and i just i
love to do something stimulating and
these puzzles are very intellectually
stimulating
it's important if you're gonna and also
it's important and it's nice to get some
brain activity some exercise for your
noggin and have a good time
and the game is just like so cute like
they have all these cute little
characters and they help you solve the
puzzle the puzzles and the more you play
the more characters you get um so they
get new characters and challenging
puzzles added all the time and they have
thousands of levels so like you could
really play until
until it's time to go to bed um download
best fiends for free today on the app
store or google play and that's friends
without the r so best fiends f-i-e-n-d-s
and i just feel like when it comes to
phone games i am a source who can be
trusted um and i think we've learned
that over the past couple weeks i agree
completely thank you for that claudia
mm-hmm
it's a pleasure okay there we go phew
the world is the universe is balanced
again
i don't know if you added this as a
story i'm sure you didn't because like i
don't know if anyone really cares but
you know that the new york times yes
it's a story it's a story of course
we talk about wordle every single day
and now wordles in the news of course we
care so many thoughts so many questions
okay okay
it's the fifth story though so you're
gonna have to wait a while i guess i
could have just bumped it to number one
but but it's not that big of a news no
the big news though from yesterday um
was that whoopi goldberg caused chaos on
abc's the view on monday when she
insisted that the holocaust was quote
not about race while discussing a
tennessee school district's recent ban
of the pulitzer prize winning
prize-winning graphic novel mouse about
a holocaust survivor will be argued that
the genocide was broader than a race
based injustice she said quote the
holocaust isn't about race no it's not
about race it's about man's inhumanity
to man
other view co-hosts were quick to
disagree anna navarro said well it's
about white supremacy that's what it's
about it's about going after jews and
gypsies will be retorted but these are
two groups of white people you're
missing the point the minute you turn it
into race it goes down this alley let's
talk about it for what it is it's how
people treat each other it's it's a
problem it doesn't matter if you're
black or white because black white jews
italians everybody eats each other
i just think it's important to note that
there are other races like
jude like i actually think a lot of
people don't know this is that judaism
is a race like it's a part of your dna
that's why it comes up in your 23andme
like it is
it is a race so that's obviously an
extremely incorrect statement on
whoopi's behalf which is disappointing
to say the least but i'm also just
completely unclear on what the point she
was trying to make was okay so it's not
about race which is incorrect but so
what is it about
she's saying i've watched a video like
many times i watched it a few times too
like trying to understand like what
point is she even trying to make um
it's
it's rat and failing to make it's rather
confusing i mean obviously the holocaust
is all about racing that's just like
baseline holocaust
knowledge like the arrogant race you
know like
i feel like hitler would have would have
admitted it too like he says yes gypsies
uh jews and the black community they
were all considered inferior races right
to hitler's crew of you know blonde eyed
blonde hair blue eyed aryans yeah no
there are direct quotes that's why the
whole thing happened he's like don't get
it twisted this is about you know a
superior race
so obviously like he wanted to be clear
on his motives this is very clear
clearly very factually inaccurate i
think some of the other women like tried
to chime in and
clear it up but i don't think that they
really even have the resources or
knowledge to
explain to what be how wrong that she
was so i mean i hope that today on the
show or at least this week on the show
they bring in an actual expert to clear
this up because like there are people
who are watching this who are like oh
you know it's well first of all
holocaust education is just like in the
tank right now
but also there might be people who are
like no it's not about race it was about
religion this is a religion so i hope
that they you know on the same platform
where they shared this fallacy they
clear it up and explain one why was
about race and two why it's really
damaging to the jewish community to like
kind of write them out of the holocaust
um
yeah and you know what like i
i love whoopi goldberg like i feel like
i've i've loved her for a long time and
i've like respected her for a long time
um
and of course like if you know she
misspoke
and she didn't really understand what
she was saying like who better than me
understands that i do so i i think that
this is actually especially given that
we're living in a time where you know
anti-semitism is at an all-time high and
there's just so much misinformation like
people thinking like jews are
responsible for covet and that that jews
got better vaccines than everyone else
like it's moronic so i just think it's
like a dangerous thing to say and not
course correct and i just do think
selfishly i would love this to be
some sort of teachable moment where you
know a holocaust survivor could come i
just think there's never going to be
enough holocaust education so if this is
something that spurs a holocaust
education week on the view then i'm here
for it i am yeah and it's that's pending
whoopi thinks what she said was
incorrect i don't know if she does since
yesterday yesterday she put out um an
apology she said on today's show i said
the holocaust is not about race but
about man's inhumanity to man i should
have said that it's about both
so
the apology was uh
weak honestly but then she also went on
stephen colbert last night to promote
her new lifetime movie and this came up
um as part of the conversation and she
said obviously as a black person i think
of race as being something that i can
see
she um
concluded saying don't write me anymore
i get it i'm going to take your word for
it and never bring it up again
which i mean i want to watch the whole
it's not the lesson that's not the
lesson
i i just read like quotes of the
interview and i do want to watch the
whole clip for context but that's not
the lesson here
yeah i do want to watch the whole clip
for tone because when you read it it
sounded hella condescending but maybe
she said it differently
yeah she said she said a lot she also
said it upset a lot of people which was
never ever my intention people were very
angry and said no we are a race and i
understand i felt differently i respect
everything everyone is saying to me i
don't want to fake apologize i am very
upset the people misunderstood what i
was saying and because of it they are
saying i'm anti-semitic and denying the
holocaust and all these things that
would never occur to me i thought we
were having a discussion about it which
everyone is having i don't think
i don't think she's a holocaust denier
like that's that's a jump no but i think
she's mis
she's misunderstanding here i don't
think it was the viewers who
misunderstood i think she's
misunderstanding
the holocaust
and if the viewers did misunderstand
it's because she made
a bizarre point in a very unclear way
like i still am not sure what exactly
she was trying to say so i don't think
it's really on us for misunderstanding i
do think it's on her for misspeaking um
and this is just like you know what like
i really i do love whoopi goldberg like
i would really hope for this to be
an ex like
not that not to make an example out of
it but just to have it be now brought to
a platform where we're all talking about
the holocaust like that's always in my
opinion a great thing no matter how we
got there totally and to have it be a
learning moment i mean the view is meant
to be like a news information show so
this shouldn't be happening on the view
yeah no it shouldn't be happening but it
happened yesterday and i think that they
should bring someone on to explain to
the viewers because there are a lot of
people at home who are left feeling
confused over this and i think it could
make for a really good powerful
conversation so i hope that they do that
we'll see what they do today on the show
i mean her comments from stephen colbert
make me feel like it's like the book is
closed here but i do think considering
she made the the statements on the show
that any sort of like she has to clear
it up it should just happen on the show
and i think it would benefit the
everyone everyone would benefit everyone
i think everyone would get something out
of it also it was so crazy to watch the
clip because the producers started to
like play music to sort of like play her
off so to help her dislodge her foot
from her mouth and she could not just
stop talking
i they were playing music so loud i
literally thought my spotify started
playing cause i'm like why is there
music playing over people's voices and
then i realized like they were trying to
help her help herself and she couldn't
she just didn't stop she couldn't she
did not stop it was so effort i was
confused two efforts i was like what is
this music and i've seen a lot of clips
from the view and i i've never really
seen that like bad long oscar speech
play-off
tactic
in that capacity i don't watch it all
the time so maybe they do that all the
time but it was like it was painful
yeah and i just want to say i think ev
race is like a huge topic of
conversation and i think that a lot of
people look and perceive race based on
their own experience so obviously would
be as a black woman would have a totally
different opinion and experience on race
and so
while i understand that i just do think
it's a really small-minded way of living
yeah and also that's where i disagree
with her of of looking at the world in
two of looking through history and
you know
only seeing history through the lens of
how we live today
i think you know these women need a
history lesson
yeah it was you know it was no bueno but
you know what i'm cautiously optimistic
let's see what happens today let's see
what we'll be saying tomorrow i'm
hopeful that there's an opportunity here
i really am well i haven't like until
this opportunity is squandered i i
really think that they can do a lot with
their platform
well now that whoopi's in the news as it
pertains to the jewish community there
is um
a lot of people talking about her name
mm-hmm
i did not realize i mean maybe i did but
i think if you asked me yesterday before
this i would have thought i would have
said what be goldberg's her real name
i thought it was and you would have
thought she was jewish and i would i
think i would have thought i thought she
was jewish yeah i think so
so i actually um i recently found out
that her name is not really born whoopi
goldberg and that she's not jewish but
up until that point i did think she was
jewish too and now that people are just
talking about whoopi goldberg um they're
i'm not entirely sure when the name
change and how the name change came to
be but you know people on tick tock
which means nothing by the way but a lot
of people are saying she was breaking
into hollywood and changed her name to
sound more jewish so that she would have
more success which um
she doesn't sit right with me like at
all
um but i don't know if that's the case
but that's like that is like what a lot
of people believe i don't know if she's
really ever spoken about it but her name
is not whoopi goldberg and she is not
jewish no which was a shock to learn and
now learning and i'm like okay that's
pretty bizarre and also like if you want
to appropriate jewish culture like at
least learn the history and and share
facts and don't like diminish
trauma and our experience throughout
history that's the baseline yeah we
welcome everyone we welcome everyone you
want to be jewish change your name sure
short short come just we um
we talk about the holocaust and we
believe it was about race no but we
don't believe it was about race but also
um
she did it sounds like she converted if
you want to be jewish company jewish she
just changed her name
no i know i was putting like a nice spin
on it it's [ __ ] weird
yeah it's bizarre it's bizarre but again
i don't know that for for a fact that
that was the reason why she changed it
so i'm not gonna
it's all alleged
okay yeah no but i i saw the same thing
and i'm not on tick tock so
yeah what other reason is there
makes you think yeah goldberg that's
like the most jewish name on the planet
i mean that's what they named the tv
show the goldbergs like right it's like
quintessential judaism name it's very
like historic and
rooted in ancestor jewish ancestry right
so
just get the ancestry part what do you
think it does make you think yeah
okay well we'll keep you posted on any
um
developments and if they do anything on
the show today to sort of remedy this
messy situation and also just
underscores the importance of holocaust
education in schools and that the book
mouse should definitely not be banned
should never have been banned
yeah
yeah
okay i read it when i was little yeah no
it's it's a very powerful book for kids
if people don't know it's a graphic
novel and it tells the story of the
holocaust but using animals
and it's like a comic book yeah yeah
graphic novel and it's an easy way
for kids to you know understand and and
learn about the holocaust the atrocities
yeah no it's very um
powerful
our next story like um the movie a
beautiful life
i've not seen it
what
no i don't think i've seen that movie
jackie you have to see it it's like do
you know what it's about which one is
that is that the one with um
it's like a french film um about this
jewish father and son during the
holocaust and how the father literally
makes the whole holocaust for his son
out to be like a video game not a video
game like a game he's like we have to
run away from and it's like the
watching this young jewish boy's lens
of
the holocaust but through his like like
the game his father set it out to be and
it's like it's really sad wow no i
haven't seen that
it's a good if if you're looking to
educate yourself on the holocaust
that i wouldn't start with that one but
it's a good one yeah there's a lot of
books movies resources um
definitely check them out
our next story other big news of the day
tom brady has officially retired from
football after 22 legendary seasons
tom brady announced his retirement this
morning even though there was
speculation all weekend and like
official reports that he retired even
though he hadn't said anything but now
he said something he said i've always
believed the sport of football is an
all-in proposition if 100 competitive
commitment isn't there you won't succeed
and success is what i love so much about
the game there's a physical mental and
emotional challenge every day that has
allowed me to maximize my highest
potential and i've tried my very best
these past 22 years there are no
shortcuts to success on the field or in
life
this is difficult for me to write but
here it goes i am not going to make that
competitive commitment anymore
i have loved my nfl career and now it is
time for me to focus my time and energy
on other things that require my
attention
okay i just want to say like someone
playing professional sports for 22 years
is so impressive like you know as an
athlete you don't have such a long shelf
life for a career because you know you
got older and injuries so anyone who can
sustain 22 years in the nfl like has my
utmost respect but i do wonder like why
he didn't retire last year because you
know to go out on top like you're you
know you're one of the oldest players in
the league and you still got the super
bowl what a way to go out um and to
you know the next year like if i were
him like i would have waited and won one
more super bowl and then retired
i guess so yeah it might have been like
buttoned up nicer if he
went out on top but like he is still
going out on top and
it's oh it's crazy there's been so much
speculation about him retiring for so
long and like now the day is here but i
feel like also i mean i'm sure he's
retiring and staying retired but i do
don't you feel like people go into
retirement and then come out all the
time
well
well his crew of friends yeah like gronk
went into retirement and then tom brady
was like let's do it one more time and
he just came back out for two seasons i
don't know if this means that gronk is
going to go back into retirement also i
have to assume
oh i'm yeah i don't know but i mean this
is huge like sports news and i agree 22
years is incredible he is the goat as
they say
and
it's a it's i was over
i was in my room and zach was watching
sports news on the couch so i heard some
stuff that they were saying and they
were talking about how like the game is
changing and it's kind of like a young
man's game now and then this is really
the time for tom brady to go and i feel
like with him leaving i don't know how
in what ways the game is changing
but i do feel like it is you know a
change of the guard yeah no he was like
the way i mean i know literally nothing
about the football but the way that i
had perceived it was he was definitely a
part of this like eli manning peyton
manning like o.g
great quarterback crew and one by one
they've all
you know left the league and he was kind
of the last one standing because he was
probably in my opinion like the best one
um again my opinion means literally
nothing
so i just want to say i'm happy for him
i'm happy for his kids you know like as
a the greatest football player of all
time i can't imagine that you're able to
be that home as much as you're able to
be home as much as you would want to so
that's very exciting for his kids and
for giselle and you love to see it
yeah that is very exciting and he's
earned you know the right to spend all
of his time
at leisure if that's what he chooses to
do who knows what he'll do next i feel
like
it must be hard to go from like
being a professional athlete which is
such a structured lifestyle to then
actual retirement so maybe we'll see him
you know broadcasting maybe we'll see
him starting a liquor company who knows
i could definitely see him you know
being an entrepreneur i'm sure he
already is invested in a lot of like
sports companies like drink companies um
so this is not the last we'll be seeing
of tom brady in my opinion yeah i don't
think so either but this is a big news
in the sports world and i'm just happy
for his family and it's been a wonderful
career this is all you could hope for
when you do eventually retire and to go
out being tom brady the goat
it's nice must be nice and being
and it must be nice to be leaving the
nfl just as handsome as what you were
when you entered it
yeah he's quite so hot he's very very
handsome
i would say and i'm just i think it's
beautiful
okay are you ready for our next story
sure
it's a little movie news grease prequel
series is coming it's called the rise
enough
the rise of the pink ladies on paramount
plus
and the cast has been announced though i
don't recognize any of the names maybe i
would recognize their photos this is
going to be a 10 episode series about
the rise of the pink ladies um and it
will star newcomers marissa davila as
jane cheyenne isabelle wells as olivia
ahri
notora
as cynthia trisha fucara as nancy a lot
of other newcomers but i think this is a
great idea for a show
i just think it's enough with greece
already like for real one grease two
grease three like there's never enough
grease grease live i love grace
i'm not like impassioned by greece at
all like i don't know if it's really a
story that was like that worth telling
um and i i don't feel connected to
greece at all like i do love olivia
newton and i love the soundtrack but
like i'm not a greased girly like i have
greasy in my hair but that's it
i love grease i think it's such a great
story i think the music is so good and
this could this will either be cringe or
iconic based on like who's doing it what
the script is like etc but i'm feeling
hopeful i feel like this is such a cute
idea
i'm feeling like i really don't give a
[ __ ] like at all even though i'm not
seeing anyone cast as rizzo and like
what are the pink ladies without rizzo
well is it a prequel like
like the month before greece starts or
like 60 years before oh it's 20 24 years
before
no i'm sorry they're not even alive it's
rizzo it's four years before the
original it's it's taking place in 1954
and greece takes place in 1950 so are
the pink ladies
the pink ladies are in the eighth grade
no it's like the pink lady yeah the ones
we know are in the eighth grade i think
like they're not in the film it's like
the it's the girls who started the pink
ladies yeah yeah that's what i'm getting
if you do the math yeah
okay like i really don't care and
honestly i cancelled my paramount plus
so i don't think this is going to be the
thing to get me to re
re
n rene re
re up read renew renew
um i don't know where i stand with my
paramount plus subscription i feel like
i i'm locked out you know what i'm
locked out of yeah like i was going
through my subscriptions one day and
then i was like oh my god i paid for
paramount plus because i've never even
felt even remotely motivated to open up
the app and i was like this is a waste
of money and i cancelled it i can't get
into my hbo max account
everyone is telling me to watch the
gilded age i
i know i'm going to be watching it but
there's only one episode out i'm not
watching it episodically i want to enjoy
the whole season so i'm literally so
[ __ ] excited for the show i can't
even tell you like i'm obsessed with
like gilded age new york it's julian
fellowes like nothing there's a cavalier
in it
i'm going to be watching don't you worry
about me but i'm not watching one week
at a time i'm sorry
so i started it and i have two things to
say cynthia nixon is extremely
distracting like
why is miranda in 1800s new york or
whatever it is it makes no sense i agree
she's so distracting agreed agreed even
in the trailer i was distracted and the
yeah and she's like
just not it and then also um
the acting is really like it's like
terrible like it's really bad acting i
love the show it was gorgeous but the
acting it's like
so
bad like i can't even tell you with how
bad it is
oh my god like i would say it's giving
community theater but that is an insult
to the actors at the community theater
that is shocking news i'll still watch
and hopefully it gets better but like
it's cosplay it's like i'm sure the
budget is there the sets are there like
and to have the actors drop the ball
no but like the green screens are like
it's giving cosplay like it's weird
there's something really weird about the
show i can't put my finger on like what
it doesn't have like the realness of
downton abbey and like you could say
what you want about downton abbey you
could not say the acting was bad like it
was gorgeous and every field they stood
in wasn't cgi there's a scene where
people get on a boat and there's like
this storm in the water and it's like
literally a coloring book it's like fake
it's so weird oh my i think i need to
watch it just watch it so i want to get
your opinion just to have a take on this
and also to maybe maybe i could
try and
figure out what's gone so wrong here
what's wrong with it it's because i mean
it's hard to recreate like
settings from 100 years ago 150 years
ago in new york which is a city which is
like but that part of the session is
very good
that part of the set is very good like
whereas at downton they had all of high
clear castle as their playground and
their set they and that doesn't the
nature of the english countryside
doesn't change
so
no that's true just watch it also i
heard some disheartening news that the
downton movie number two has been pushed
again
it was supposed to come out in march and
it's kidding it's so disappointing it's
terrible it's horrible like what about
the fans what about us
yeah do they know that there are people
out here literally waiting with baited
breath no
yeah apparently there are like actual
like real downton fans who are taking up
the cause so we're in good hands
but
it's
it's not good
now are you ready terrible are you ready
for our next story speaking
of cynthia
nixon if it's a story that's brought to
you by thrive cosmetics yes because i
love thyroid cosmetics i'm wearing their
mascara
me oh by the way i'm not wearing mascara
today but i've had their mascara for
well over a year i saw it on a facebook
ad like months ago and it actually works
just as good if not better in person
than it did on the ad it's amazing and
they're just a great
a great company so their high
performance beauty and skincare products
are are made with clean skin loving
ingredients which means no parabens
sulfates
it's certified 100 vegan and cruelty
free and their thrive cosmetics because
every purchase supports organizations
that help women thrive so their eye
products like the liquid lash extensions
mascara which is the mascara we were
just talking about is their best selling
product it's ultra lengthening eye
opening mascara and it lasts all day
without clumping smudging or flaking it
mimics the look of a lash extension
without damaging glue or expensive salon
prices it's super easy to remove and its
clean nourishing ingredients support
longer stronger and healthier looking
lashes they also have amazing skin care
products
i personally like their eye lifting eye
cream so it instantly lifts tightens and
brightens skin around your eyes with
line smoothing hydration
um it softens soothes and deeply
moisturizes your skin while instantly
reducing dark circles and puffiness so
if you're listening to this podcast it's
probably time for an eye cream and i
highly recommend the one from thrive
cosmetics
um it's a great time to try thrive
cosmetics for yourself right now you can
get 15 off your first order when you
visit thrive cosmetics cosmetics is
spelled c-a-u-s-e
medics dot com slash toast that's thrive
cosmetics c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s
dot com slash toast for 15 off your
order your first order at thrive
cosmetics check it out
yes thank you very much okay our next
story some exciting news for you claudia
and just like that has unveiled a
trailer for a new documentary to be
released alongside the season finale
very game of thrones yeah i think i'm an
episode behind so i don't think this is
going to spoil anything right no no no
fans of the hbo max original series and
just like that need not fret about the
upcoming end to the show's first season
the streamer dropped a trailer for and
just like that the documentary on monday
that will coincide with the season
finale airing on thursday the dock will
go behind the scenes of the making of
the new show which picks up the lives of
carrie miranda and charlotte almost two
decades after the original series ended
um and it just shows like the process of
them making the show and like all of the
emotions and logistics that went into it
which is giving me like game of thrones
because they did that um for game of
thrones after the finale they had a
documentary about like the making of
game of thrones which was so interesting
because it was an extremely involved
show and for many seasons and like this
just feels right this just feels very
like light
but
so
i actually saw somewhere like you know
the three of them sitting down they're
all executive producers of the show now
like talking and
i don't i don't know if it's from the
same the same footage as this
documentary but they were just talking
about how old they were and like i just
can't like for real i actually can't
yeah i'm sure they'll talk about like
the you know what it means to them and
show that all the different changes
which i think if you're a big fan of the
show it could be really interesting it's
just it seems like a lot also is there a
season is there gonna be a season two
is there meant to be a season two on
this show
i think the show is very it's doing very
well i think it's too it's definitely
doing better than i thought it was gonna
do because i actually really like it and
the thing is i'm a big fan of the
franchise and like a decently big fan of
the the reboot and i couldn't find one
iota of energy to put towards watching
this documentary like i just don't care
yeah i feel that i think there are a lot
of people who do care though and it's
just like more content from the ladies
and i'm sure they'll bring up like a lot
of nostalgia right
and well i would i'm curious as to when
they recorded it because i would love
for them to talk about some of the
how the show was being received
yeah i think it's probably mostly like
the making of
this season
but
yeah that would be interesting because
the show is being is well received and i
wonder if they had a lot of jitters
because reboots in general just
really don't often hit the mark most of
the time so i wonder if they were
worried about that or they knew that
like you know the integrity of the show
would remain intact
i mean
the thing is i like the i can't tell if
the show is good or i just like really
like like sex in the city and i love the
characters because like
i'm enjoying it but that doesn't mean
it's a good show do you know what i mean
yeah no i i do know what you mean
but i think these days it's so with
especially with there's being so much
out there to watch that like if you're
not enjoying something you don't watch
it so i think it must be good if you're
continuing to watch it when you could
spend your time watching other stuff you
know like you couldn't finish emily in
paris well i won't be watching the
documentary that's no i did finish emily
in paris but i didn't i know
i knew as i was watching it that i
wasn't enjoying it yeah
yeah so and i mean it's also different
for you because like you feel compelled
to finish stuff like for this show as
opposed to if it was just your free will
like what would you leave on what would
you turn off and any time you do turn
off
really true when you turn off a show
it's like making a statement on this
show like i couldn't even finish it
yeah
that's true actually yeah so there's a
lot of pressure well this is no game of
thrones there is a lot of pressure but
this is no game of thrones and i don't
know if this is totally necessary i
thought you were gonna say sex in the
city has been you know renewed for a
season two and three so i haven't heard
about the renewal right like was this
just meant to be a little time capsule
catch up with like a bookmark or is this
like really their next
career
act
you know what i'm down for both but i
actually do think that that would would
be like a cool
way to like do it like this is just a
moment in time we're checking back in
with the ladies maybe you'll hear from
us in another 10 years
yeah but i just feel like hollywood is
incapable of doing something like that
they're like oh wait there was there was
a modicum of success for this let's
beat this dead horse dead horse yeah
they they don't know when it's time to
stop and like maintain the integrity of
a franchise
exactly
now it is time for our fifth and final
story which i'm excited to talk to you
about
the new york times has bought wordle for
a price in the low seven figures
the new york times i was going to sing
but i guess i just won't oh i mean you
took your you hesitated you hesitated no
i was literally i was literally like as
i was like
i saw
it's fine just continue just don't mind
me
the new york times has purchased wordle
the daily word game that has recently
taken the internet by storm the
publication announced the acquisition in
a press release on monday writing as the
times looks to entertain more solvers
with puzzles every day especially during
these anxious times we're thrilled to
announce that we've acquired wordle the
stimulating and widely popular daily
word game that has become a cultural
phenomenon wordle which gives players
six tries to guess a five letter mystery
word will join the new york times's
games portfolio of engaging original
puzzle games that delight and challenge
solvers every day
i'm not gonna lie that's mad smart
because like i could see this first of
all everyone loves the new york times
puzzle app i do the minis sometimes like
they are known for their like games and
it's like you know um
brain stimulating games so this
definitely fits in with their portfolio
do you think that means like in in the
newspaper they'll be like the wordle
will be in the paper now and people oh
actually how would that work no
that wouldn't work no no but uh yeah no
that's pretty cool for them i guess it's
smart i just feel like up until i read
this news like word it was just gonna be
one of those things like hq like yeah
you know quiz up remember you know where
everyone's really into it and then it
sort of dissipates maybe like the new
york times's involvement will make it
have more staying power and it'll just
be a part of people's rights i do think
so but i also wonder if now it's going
to be part of their games app and it's
like you have to download their app in
order to play in which case like i'm
fully out
yeah no if they make me download an app
like i like where we're at now i think
it's perfect i do think it's so
interesting how like this isn't
a crazy unique
concept you know it was it's not even an
app it's literally like a janky website
with someone who came up with this like
random game idea and in a matter of
weeks
and i like to think i'm partially
responsible um in a matter of weeks they
are now a multi-millionaire like i just
think that's crazy yeah i agree and i
also think like this is the height of
wordle like there's not
going to be a better time to sell
whatever they got for this is take the
money and run i'm happy for this
creator
um
um i did see a really funny tick tock
okay about because when people were
first started talking about wordle like
a while ago i downloaded wordle in the
app store and i ended up with like this
totally random like i'm like this is not
it because this is not what i'm seeing
on like people's instagram stories
and this guy
who's who created the wordle app like
years ago he like doesn't even work on
it anymore he's like my app went viral
overnight because like everyone thinks
that it's brutal like he showed us how
much money he was making like it was
actually so funny and really interesting
because every single person i know who
got into wordle
just downloaded that app they thought it
was totally the right thing and it was
completely wrong like the the idea that
every single person on the planet was
going to a website on safari was so like
not possible yeah so everyone went to
the app store
that's really funny and it was the game
any good
no it was like the dumbest game i'm like
this is what people are playing this
game sucks that's so funny i haven't
done my wordle yet today it's just like
a word scramble me neither but we both
have been doing talordle i don't do it
every day because it's infuriating it's
it's infuriating
painful than wordle even because it's
like
yeah it's harder
it's more niche but it should also make
it easier because you wouldn't guess
words that like have no association with
taylor swift that's what taylor is it's
taylor swift themed wordle and it's
infuriating
i just want to say the girls who started
it it says at the top i'm not sure who
it is but it's two girls who host a
taylor swift themed podcast and so they
have their podcast link right at the top
of the homepage and taylor went viral
and it was just like a really smart
marketing idea like good for them
i thought about gene postal but it would
be too easy
to guess all of our five letters i
thought about doing
no i thought we should do toastal and
the word of the day every day is toast
and everyone wins every day right no
it's it would be really too easy i
thought about it too
yeah
okay well those are the fast five
stories i feel as though you needed to
know them in a major way
um and now we're gonna watch into some
tv recap claude what is going on with
the kids
so the tv recap is brought to you by
babel whether it's saving more and
spending less getting organized
um there's a lot of worthwhile goals to
set up for yourself this year and at the
top of our list is learning a new
language with babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions not only is
learning a new language a fun and
engaging new hobby you can use it while
you check off traveling more from your
list jackie you're on your hobby journey
and i know that you've been taking baby
lessons can you tell me about that yes
babel is a great place to learn a new
language they make all of the lessons
like snackable it's not too much to
digest at once and i mean if you have a
lot of time on your hands or you have
lofty goals or you're traveling or you
just want to expand your mind learning a
new language is a way to do all of those
things and babble is the resource for
you if you are looking to do it because
they make it really easy and digestible
and not so overwhelming as you would
think it would be to learn a new
language
so their 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective there are so many ways to
learn with babble
and they also offer 14 different
languages like spanish french italian
and german when i just went to um
rome i actually took a couple of babel
lessons like if you're on your way to
the play on the plane like it's just a
great thing to do so you have a basic
understanding when you're traveling it's
just like way safer to know
some common phrases in the in the local
language so right now when you purchase
a three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
so that's six months for the price of
three just when you go to babel.com
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com promo code t-m-t
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com code tmt babel
language for life okay so i want to
start with euphoria
because
there was like a crazy episode on sunday
a lot of people it ended in a very
mysterious way people aren't entirely
sure what happened there is a conspiracy
theory that zendaya's character roo did
overdose and that's what happened at the
end she was you know in a church and i
think it was meant to be her funeral i
don't know some people think she died i
don't think she died maybe she overdosed
she was on a downward spiral we should
we know we saw this coming um
and it's just devastating
but for me like the there was like an
an emmy someone earned themselves an
emmy nomination
um last night and it was jacob lordy's
dad in the show who is from burlesque
who were just talking about eric davis
and also obviously grace grey's anatomy
but obviously you've never seen that
people were like other people so
offended mad yeah
so he basically has been living this
like crazy double life his whole life
and we got his back story last week it
was actually really sad so when he was
in high school he was like you know
super masculine his dad was really hard
on him but he knew he was gay and he was
in love with his best friend derek and
he he had a girlfriend and he loved his
girlfriend but he loved derek the most
and one night him and derek like finally
like kiss and they go out and it's just
like this beautiful moment and the next
morning he wakes up and his girlfriend
tells him that
she's pregnant and literally his
girlfriend is now his wife and
he never got to see derek again so like
you understand like his villain origin
story but he's been living this double
life he's like this prick who like
cheats on his wife and has sex with
men and nobody knows he's gay but he
gets wasted this episode and he comes
when he just tells his whole family he's
like i don't even regret living my
double life i regret having you kids i
hate you guys like it was this crazy
like seven minute monologue
and he definitely earned himself some
sort of nomination like it was really
well executed it was like a crazy part
of the episode um
and also sydney sweeney was
impeccable like i told you last week
she's in love with jacob alerty and like
it's driving her crazy like she is
her acting is just impeccable and she is
on this crazy journey like trying to
make him like her and he does like her
but he has motives he has to get back
together with his other girl because she
has this blackmail on him so he's not
really able to focus on sydney sweeney
even though like i do think they might
be otp
but so she invites everyone over to her
house to celebrate maddie's birthday and
so maddie is jacob lordy's girlfriend
and the fact that sydney sweeney is
[ __ ] jacob lord is like you know
she's betraying her best friend but she
doesn't care because she's so in love
with jacob lordy and it's a really tough
night for her because like jacob lordy
is with maddie so she gets wasted like
beyond wasted she's like singing and
dancing in the other room everyone's
like what's going on with cassie
and
then they all get in the hot tub and
like sydney sweetie projectile vomits on
everyone because she was like so wasted
it was it and she's like sobbing her
mom's pulling her out of the pool she
can't stop throwing up
it was unbelievable acting like and
she's just she's going crazy and it's so
believable like sydney sweeney can cry
on cue she still looks so beautiful like
it's
this is definitely sydney sweeney's like
season because maddie's like not really
as prevalent this season it's really all
about cassie so i do think cassie will
get herself um nominated for an emmy
every episode she's just more talented
it's it's beyond so um i don't really
know like what happened in the episode
like i've been reading theories and
stuff but i don't think we'll really
know until next week um so a lot of like
crazy things happen but the storyline
overall i don't think was super moved
forward yet like we just were setting
the scene this week
okay
good nice the other thing i watched was
was rupaul's drag race jackie and i have
to tell you
so there it's a historic season there is
a straight cis male drag queen
wow
it's really shocking
especially like so the community i think
is like torn on it i happen to think uh
uh his name is
maddie matty the magnificent or whatever
and
he's actually really good like he has a
unique style of drag he's not like
overly glam he's very like campy and he
does like really crazy makeup and
costumes
it's not terrible it's actually he's
definitely better than some of the other
queens who are there like it's just
shocking and when the queen
found out that he was straight like
they were just like they were choking
like they couldn't believe it it was
it's sh it's shocking it really is and
he didn't outwardly come out and tell
everyone roo was interviewing them all
individually in the work room and they
were like all listening in and so roo
was like maddie you're our first
straight drag queen and they were like
shuck the other queens now
in terms of who i fully support
cornbread has my heart she has my soul
and i do think michelle visage giving
her like really nasty um
feedback was so unnecessary especially
when cornbread went on to win the
challenge like make it make sense
michelle michelle's kind of losing it um
ross matthews looks amazing and they've
had amazing guest judges lizzo was on
and no one has ever had more fun than
lizzo the day she shot rupaul's drag
race like she was living and then they
did a lip sync to her song and you could
just tell she like loves the show and
like she was just having the best time
that's so fun who else alicia keys so oh
cool alicia keys i've only watched the
first two episodes alicia keys was great
she was definitely like just loving
supporting you know everyone on their
own she was just like you know she's
very like emotional not emotional like
she's deep she's very deep yeah so you
could just tell there was like this
mutual love and respect coming from
alicia it was beautiful this season's
really good rue is like unhinged like
rue just you know rue created this
entire universe of tv shows world of
wonder he calls it and he it's
whatever he wants he has complete
creative control and he's just like he's
just crazy i can't explain it but he's
just insane like he says the craziest
[ __ ] you can't believe that they say it
on tv like it's actually insane
yeah
that's so fun um so
it's so good i really like cornbread um
and i also really like oh george's so
there's this queen
georges who's like kind of famous
already
um
and so when everyone comes into the work
room and sees that she's on the show
like they're quaking because like they
already follow her on instagram she's
like a huge influencer in the drag
community and she's
so stunning it's like actually not fair
like it's not even a competition like
she's like a singer she's a triple
threat she's amazing georges is up there
for me she she definitely has what it
takes to go all the way but right now
there's no clear winner okay because i
was just gonna ask you who you who you
think um would win but also do you not
think it would be
is it meant to be like more amateurs
like if george just wins does she not
already have a leg up
no because honestly i think really ever
i don't know actually how it works but i
think that you're really considered an
amateur until you get on drag race or i
don't know is that
i don't know i really don't know how
like the logistics work but it is crazy
that there's someone who's like already
very influential on the show but that
has happened before yeah that's cool
though that adds like a fun element so i
don't know i don't know who's going to
win because like i always pick a loser
like i wanted candy muse she lost i want
to check who lay she like i everyone i
pick loses so unfortunately i think that
means cornbread is going to lose but i
love cornbread she's
everything
everything okay that's exciting i hope
that you you know it's not a 49ers
situation for you
no it is like it literally is like i
wanted gottmick to win like i just
literally i don't know how to pick them
assuming
and then the final thing i watched was
summerhouse and
it really is jackie it's crazy it's like
such a good show and it's so layered
especially because you know so much is
going on but i know you're very invested
in the craig and page of it all and i
can tell you what's going on right now
so it's a couple months post vermont
and basically after vermont andrea
andrea was like totally into page and he
was like i don't want to see other
people and paige was just like i'm in
like the season of my life like i'm just
not ready
so it's been like awkward and when they
get back to the house they definitely
start like rekindling their connection
but she does admit she's been hooking up
with craig for the last two months
um completely unexclusively like they're
just hooking up and he knows it and she
knows it but she's definitely intrigued
by him so she's like in the house
flirting with andrea but she like you
know gets in bed and calls craig so
you really don't know where she where
she like where she um is leaning towards
obviously we know in real life that
she's
in love with craig and so we're rooting
for it so hard but andrea's making it
very tough on page but craig does come
to visit very soon there was an episode
last night i haven't seen it yet he does
come to visit um and i just really hope
we get to see like their world when
romance it will be awkward because
andrea is full-time in the house
got it i didn't realize he was going to
be a part of the summer house cast now
maybe like just from winterhouse but i
guess that makes sense and that does add
additional layers
so then there's just a lot it's very
layered so then there's this whole story
line with lindsay like the first night
she gets there you know lindsay i think
has always been like very clear crawly
energy like independent woman with a
dash of chaos you know
um and so she's just being like you know
more chaotic than normal and no one
really knows why
and then she shares with carl which is
actually a really sweet moment knowing
now that lindsay and carl are like in a
full-fledged relationship
she shares that she
left winter house with jason and they
were like not exclusive but they were
dating consistently
and she was feeling very weird and she
thought it was because of the coveted
vaccine like her hormones were very
weird and she went to the doctor and
found out she was pregnant
she found out she was pregnant on a
monday
and by wednesday she was in the
emergency room having a miscarriage
and
she said that you know
if those weren't the circumstances like
she fully intended to keep the baby
um and she's like working through the
trauma and she doesn't really know how
she feels but she feels okay
um she thinks maybe like the trauma will
hit her later so it was just like a i
couldn't believe it was like a crazy
turn of events and i kind of loved that
she was confiding in carl and he was
like so there for her because now we
know that they're like in a really good
happy healthy relationship and it was
like kind of a beautiful moment in the
end but it was like a really sad story
like a
freak
moment for her yeah yeah wow so crazy
so then there's kyle and amanda
and the thing is is that like their
the whole season is leading up to their
wedding so right now it's july they're
three months away from the wedding and
they are not in a good place like kyle
is drinking a lot and amanda the first
night everyone goes out and he like
stays out till four in the morning
doesn't answer his phone everyone else
gets home at like 1 32 he's beyond
blacked out and she's like why like it's
literally the first night we're here
like why can't you just come home with
everyone and obviously she has trauma
because he did you know black out and
hook up with another girl a couple
summers ago and she's just always scared
that like he's gonna black out and not
even remember like going home with some
girl so
she has trauma she gets furious at four
in the morning throws his [ __ ] out into
the front yard he comes home and he's
like what did i do and the next morning
he's like
he's mad at her for being mad at him
it's so stupid but she does confide in
paige and sierra she says like we
actually have this document signed that
if we end up breaking up because of
kyle's drinking he has to pay my parents
back every single penny that they're
putting into this wedding so it's
obviously like something that's going on
she says like in the city over the last
couple months he's gone out blacked out
and not come home and it's like a
problem
so
we're just like it's just weird because
we know that they do get married right
so i don't know like
those are big fights to be having
how many three months before the wedding
however many months it is
i know but the thing is like i actually
think amanda batula's like an incredibly
smart girl and i like trust her judgment
so
i think it's gonna turn out to be okay
but there's a lot of weirdness okay so
danielle
she's just kind of this like random
castmate who i don't know where she fits
into the group but basically like all
the girls are obviously there for amanda
amanda's like pissed for like four days
about this thing
and danielle is like with kyle and she's
just like kind of being like a like a
pick me like
like be with the girls like yeah don't
be with kyle like kyle has enough
friends it's just like kind of lame of
her yeah um and then her boyfriend comes
and cooks this like she's this amazing
boyfriend who's like this top-notch chef
and he's like been working a lot because
he got this great new job but he comes
out for fourth of july cooks like this
huge seafood boil for everyone and she's
like mad that he's cooking all day and
like not spending time with her and he
basically says like i'm not gonna be
able to come out a lot this summer this
new job that i got just keeping me
really busy and she's like getting mad
i'm like why she's being like really
toxic it's like your boyfriend is so
cute so nice can't stop cooking for
everyone like
i'm like it sucks for sure that he can't
come but like you're really gonna start
a fight with him the one week and he
actually is there
so i'm just unclear on that and
danielle's just giving me like bad vibes
like 100 bad vibes sierra is the queen
of the hamptons um the fact that this
show ever existed without her is beyond
my comprehension her and carl even
though it's like
it's stupid because her and carl are
like flirting and you think they're
gonna hook up but he we know he ends up
with lindsay so
there's not much there but what happened
with her and austin is after after
winter house austin made it like 100
clear that he's not
interested in like really committing and
settling down she's like [ __ ] that but
he does come to visit with craig and i
do believe they hook up so we'll see
what happens there but right now there's
like her and carl but it's i don't think
it's gonna
it's not gonna last
but then the craziest thing happened
they had a fourth of july party and all
these people were there i saw remy bader
remy bader was at the party like it was
like this big hamptons party and these
like three girls are i don't know if
they already know andrea but they're
hanging out with andre andrea like jumps
in the pool with one of them
and then one of the girl i guess the
girl was like mad she got pushed in the
pool so her friend comes over and
literally
punches andrea and kicks him in the face
it was so crazy i was like what
and they had like crystal clear footage
of it i was shook and then paige disorbo
like stands up for her man and like
kicks these three girls out get the [ __ ]
out of my house iconic paige is just
i don't really know how to like put into
words someone who's so perfect like
she's so nice she's not a mean girl
she's friends with everyone she brought
a new girl maya who very interestingly
is also like a chef and she was engaged
for five years to someone from top chef
so it's like a bravo crossover it's
great
paige is so nice she doesn't get like
there's no girl drama she's a supportive
friend she's so funny she's still really
interesting she drinks a lot she has
perfect outfits like
she is literally the perfect reality
star she is yeah i feel that
i do you're making me want to watch the
house she dates
jackie it's so good and there's only
three episodes and it's a really nice
house
the vibes you were getting from winter
house i know you were like triggered by
like their gross house this house is
very big it's a mansion it's very nice
it's very clean so far there's only
three episodes i think you should watch
it okay if they're keeping it clean then
i think i can handle it that's that
sounds really nice i think maybe i'll
jump in that's i'm i'm down you've
really you've sold
you've you've sold me
okay good so that was like me literally
talking for 15 minutes straight about
the tv recap i apologize if there's
anything else i know you have a doctor's
appointment i know and we already are
running 45 minutes behind because we did
the stupid
oh my god okay let's wrap up i'm so
sorry 45 minutes late because i'm happy
for you that you got that all off your
chest
people have been begging me to recap
euphoria and summer house and i had to
get it over with and i just threw
rupaul's drag race in there too yeah i'm
done okay no i appreciate it i'm glad
for thank you guys so much
let's go
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we deliver the fast-paced stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
so uh what do you deliver the past five
stories on youtube
subscribe and like us on youtube and
leave us a nice review on podcast we
love you our instagram is still being
worked on we're fully on top of it it
should be back at some point this
millennium and we love you have a good
work in progress we will see you
tomorrow love ya bye